Qualcomm is claiming that their new
Snapdragon X Elite just be apple being
21% faster than appel's M3 chip man
Qualcomm is saying that their chip which
is slated for the second half of 2024 is
faster than the already Mass Market
produced chip in its base configuration
this has to be a joke because when you
look into it it is absolutely insane now
this Snapdragon has 50 50% more cores
and they are 12 performance cores
compared to four performance and four
efficiency cores in the M3 but it's only
21% faster and of course they did not
mention single core performance although
I will talk about this in just a bit and
the most insane thing is that they were
running this chip at 80 watts of power
worse than what intel was doing and that
is being compared to an M3 the M3 chip
is designed to work in a fanless MacBook
Air and in super thin iPads which the M3
is going to be in and in the MacBook
with the fan it is running under 20
watts in very heavy use compared to 80
now that means that the M3 gets 68 score
per watt compared to the X Elite
191 that is a massive performance per
watt difference now if you actually look
at it it should be compared to none of
Apple shifts because the M3 Pro uses 27
watts in the unbin version and the M3
Max uses up to 54 not 80 and the crazy
thing is even in a 16-in MacBook with
that M3 Max at 54 it already pushes the
fans really hard so a 80 wat chip would
have to be in a massive thick Windows
laptop with crazy cooling but even those
right there 80 watts is just insane now
the M3 Pro that uses 27 Watts that thing
scored
15,6 161 so that beats out the X Elite
while using about a third of the power
and the M3 Max which uses up to 54 Watts
Under full load scores
2,428 smoke smoking the new Snapdragon
while using a lot less power and then if
we compare the performance per watt here
the difference is massive so how could
they be using a massive 80 watts of
power well I definitely don't think that
will use that much once it ships I think
the only reason that they ran it that
high was in order to beat the M3 because
it takes a ton more power to get just a
little bit more performance for example
the M3 Max uses twice the power as M3
Pro to get just 36% more performance so
the M3 Pro's 27 watts is really the
sweet spot now Qualcomm did say that
they will have an efficiency focused 23
watt profile which sounds about right
but of course taking 80 Watts bringing
it down to about 23 the performance will
go down quite a bit and the bend M3 Pro
uses 23 watts and that scores about
13,692 now based on all of our arm chip
testing here at maxtech that should
bring the score down to about 9 to
10,000 which is about the performance of
the M2 Chip but of course using more
power now if that seems like it's way
too low look at their current sq3
processor in the Surface Pro 9 it scores
5,795 so this would mean that this new
chip would still be a really good
Improvement and it's also using a bit
more power and having a 12 core now the
sq3 was quickly forgotten because
Microsoft Surface Pro 9 with that chip
it actually cost more than even the best
Intel chip and at the time looking at
geekbench 5 it got worse performance now
people argued that you should get it for
battery life but the battery life was
not significantly better now of course
they will run this Elite chip higher
than 23 Watts I was guing about 30ish or
so but when researching I actually found
a leaked Benchmark having it run at 28
which is just a bit higher than Apple's
M3 Pro now it scored
13,21 at 28 watts compared to
14,21 for the M2 Pro which uses a bit
less power so no this thing is not a
chip that defeats Apple that is just
marketing it does slightly beat out the
M1 Pro while you using more power and as
far as performance per watt the old M1
series which is based off of the A14 is
still better so that chip uses more
power and it slightly beats out the M1
Pro but it will come out almost 3 years
after that chip and they had to run
triple the power of the already unbinned
M3 Pro but it still lost to it so they
marketed it against the M3 and we're not
even going to see that chip for another
half a year now what about the single
core performance they didn't mention it
because of course it is not as good but
I found the score in a leaked Benchmark
pushing 500 extra MHz to one core
compared to the M2 Pro it barely beats
it out but the M3 at that same clock
speed of course beats it by a lot with
that said it is still a good improvement
from their current sq3 chip and it is
slightly better than their new flagship
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 smartphone chip now
what about graphics performance well it
actually has the same Graphics as that
new mobile chip and that scores 32 FPS
in Wildlife extreme the original M1
scored 30 so it barely beats it out and
it will come out almost 4 years later
now the current entry level M3 scores 49
that is a difference of over 50 % and of
course it uses less power and it is
already out but with that said the X
Elite chip should not be compared to the
M3 that is their highest end chip so if
we take a look at the M3 Pro that scores
87 almost three times the performance
and let's not even talk about the M3 Max
and then we need to get into the actual
experience of using an arm chip with
Windows qual themselves said that it's
good Hardware but they have to use
Windows basically admitting that that is
going to be an issue because you have to
use Windows design for arm and if you
have looked at that in the past and if
you have used it you would know that it
is terrible we have tested it here with
the uh previous version and apps just
work terribly a lot of apps don't work
at all you have to use older versions
then you are limited by how much camic
and use because it's designed
differently with um 32bit running in
there and then it's super slow super
stuttery so even some of these
benchmarks that we are looking at while
running Windows instead of Android on
the graphic side it likely is going to
be worse than that and so the whole
experience gets ruined because Windows
is so far behind and Qualcomm admits
that so this whole thing is kind of
funny saying that it is 21 % better than
the M3 because of what they had to do to
reach that and everything else they just
did not talk about so while I would say
that it is great that we are having
competition and Qualcomm is stepping it
up and of course they took Engineers
from Apple that started a new company
and they bought it out in order to get
here they are still really behind you
guys go ahead and let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
below what you think of all of this go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe and check out one of the great
videos right over there this B Max and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one